- I actually was a huge super fan
when you were on American Idol.
I still am a fan.
(applause)
- I did not know this.
- I know I'm not alone;
it's the most obvious thing.
Everybody was obsessed with
you and continues to be.
But I was supposed to go to the finale
and I had tickets and I was so excited
and I was working on that show 24
and I got a call time that went too late
and I missed it and I'm still devastated.
- We hate 24 for that; I'm just kidding.
I love 24; I'm just kidding.
- But yeah, so anyway
- Oh man
- But now look it's like I make up for it.
- You didn't miss anything.
I just looked like a total boob and cried.
It was so dumb, I cried,
and they wanted me to sing.
- I cried too; I watched I crying.
I was like, she won!
- I was literally, you know
why I was crying so hard?
Yes, dreams were being
made, but also I was like,
I never have to serve a
drink to a drunk guy again.
(cheering)
- Victory.
- You left, doing The Talk, after 10 years
of doing The Talk, like how was it?
You just recently went back, how was it?
- It felt like home, you know,
when you go back to something
you've been at for so long.
And I was so excited to
go back and see everybody
and I actually felt more
sad in a way leaving,
cause it went so fast.
Like I was just there for a couple hours.
In my mind, I had built up like,
I'm going back! I'm going
back! I'm going back!
And then I was like, oh it's over.
- Oh my gosh, it must
have been a trip, though.
That's a long time to be on a show,
like to create that family.
- It's a long time, it's a long time.
And I'll just keep finding
excuses to go back.
(applause)
- I love the group though,
it's a cool group of women.
- It's a nice group.
- Yeah, I agree.
So what is it like
filming The Conners now,
is it like 30 years
after it was on?
- Yeah
- Cause I grew up with you.
I can't believe I'm sitting next to you.
Like I always get freaked out
(cheering)
because it's those people that were
constantly in your life like everyday.
Like those kind of stars that always
I get star struck with because I'm like,
wait, I was with you like everyday,
like when you grew up on
TV, like I was growing up.
- Yeah I feel that with people.
You grow up with them
and it feels so familiar.
- Not in a stalker way.
(laughing)
Like in a very safe way, yeah.
- It's incredible for me
too to be with these people
that I've known my whole life
and have this history with
and do these scenes together
that have so much built into them.
- It must be an amazing thing
to be a part of something
that was so rare.
Like I feel like Rosanne,
like Friends, MASH,
I think there's these shows
that kind of stick out in time.
There's others I'm
forgetting, but I just mean
that the cast is so perfect,
the chemistry is so perfect.
Whatever goes into play, is just perfect.
And I love that like 30 years later
ya'll are doing it again.
And you're now in your
second season, right?
(cheering)
- Yeah
- It's amazing.
- It's lucky, it's like you can't,
you just never know when you
put a group of people together
how it's going to work,
and part of it is luck
that you have the chemistry
and the relationships, yeah.
- And just to be a kid in Hollywood
that must have been hard
growing up on the show,
so it's good you had, it was
like a family environment.
That's kinda cool that you had that.
- Yeah, very cool.
- So it's fun, you're doing it again.
You're doing second season,
and you're also executive producer, right?
- I am.
- So you're acting,
you're executive producer, you're a mom.
Do you want another job, or?
(applause)
- It's funny because I left The Talk
so I would have a little more time
and then this morning I had a few hours
because I was coming here so my work day
got pushed later and I literally
didn't know what to do.
I was like, I need another job.
- There's no call time,
there's no schedule.
- Yeah.
- I panic.
Like 'cause I'm so busy all the time.
I'm with you; it's like
wait nobody is telling me
when to eat or like what to wear or, yeah.
- I function better when I have structure.
- But you have more time
for your family though
now that you're not doing
that and you're just
doing The Conners right now, right?
- I do and I get to pick
up my kids sometimes
or take them to school.
- Do they come on set ever?
- They do come on set; they
say they're coming to see me,
but I have a lot of
evidence to the contrary.
(laughing)
So they'll come when I do The Conners
and they'll run around
with all the other kids
and they say they're watching the show.
And then when I ask,
they have like no idea
what the plot was.
- Good.
- And then when I did The Talk,
they'd always say like, oh well what are
the giveaways today?
- What are the giveaways?
- And I was like, aren't
you going to come see me?
They're like no, no, no
we're coming to see you.
And then all of a sudden,
- But gimme your swag.
- Right
Then I go into like one of my kid's rooms
and there's like a new
TV and vacuum cleaner.
(laughing)
I'm like, you can't keep that.
- I mean points for getting it!
I mean that's, they're
going to run a company.
- They like order it and
everything and suddenly
there's like 14 blenders
in my living room.
(laughing)
- That's awesome, my kids do that,
we all have kids at The
Voice and there's like
a little compound there
and they always say
they're coming for me
but really they're coming
for the sugar, the
catering, and the children.
They don't even care that I'm there.
- Food is a big, the
food is a big attraction.
- God, what is it, yeah
I'm sure it's the food.
- Well and my food at my
house is like no fun, so.
- They don't like me either, weekends,
I give them weekends, they hate me.
I don't care; I'm like
Ghost of Christmas Future.
You don't want to have to work.
I'm trying to help you!